hey everybody i'm kelsey and you guys
know i'm a huge fan of dc
and superhero action films that's why
i'm so excited that i'm partnering with
buzzfeed to talk to the cast
of the suicide squad the new film
directed by james gunn
gunn's vision and larger than life
characters are played by an amazing cast
and with the film's over-the-top action
epic scale and humor this is definitely
gonna be the movie of the summer
if we find out you have personalized
license plates you don't
what no if you cough without covering
your mouth harley although
that isn't an open invitation for you to
cough without covering your
huh mouth we're going to play a little
game of who's most likely to
the suicide squad edition
margot maga who does their own stunts
easy margot
margot without a doubt it is margot
robbie as harley quinn
she's incredibly athletic the stunts and
fight choreography
i do a lot of my own stunts
captain boomerang is kind of just a
heightened version of
jai i don't know if he'd be offended
with me saying that but
i can't be too like self uh absorbed but
i honestly think the answer is
flula and javelin are that they are
i have a i have thank god they have
different hair
peacemaker john cena the five knuckle
shuffle
john john cena is on the spot well
considering john's arms are bigger than
everyone else's legs
nobody idris john cena
viola davis she's an incredible actor
and she just
comes out of the canon hard every time
who's most likely to know about the dc
universe well i hope that's
james gunn dave that's melting also
didn't get an honorable mention david
is the answer sorry just david should i
just say david david
this mountain is a comic book disguised
as a human being dave dasmaushin
is like the biggest comic book nerd out
of the group
seems like the cats definitely bonded
while playing these misfit characters
and now you can check them out in action
on the big screen
don't forget to grab your tickets to
check out james gunn the suicide squad
in theaters or streaming exclusively on
hbo max starting
august 6th and if you want to check me
out you can do so on youtube at
kelseydangerous